mi pregunta para ustedes es cuál de
estos dos valores es más grande 22.9 por
ciento o la raíz cuadrada de 0.45 y los
invito a que primero traten de resolver
esto sin usar calculadora y después usen
una calculadora pues para ver cuál de
estos dos es más grande
primero tratemos de resolverlo sin la
calculadora una cosa que podemos hacer
es decir bueno tenemos este 22.9 por
ciento
vamos a tomar aquí un número arbitrario
vamos a decir que esto es menor que un
30% y elegí el 30% porque es fácil de
calcular o al menos elevará al cuadrado
el 30 por ciento así que esto es menor
que el 30 por ciento u otra forma de
decirlo es que esto es menor que el 0.3
y después podemos tratar de comparar el
0.3 con la raíz cuadrada de punto 45 y
si el 0.3 es menor que esto de aquí pues
entonces el 22.9 por ciento también va a
ser menor ya que éste es más pequeño que
el 0.3
así que vamos a comparar a 0.3 con la
raíz cuadrada de 0.45 y ahora voy a usar
la regla de elevar al cuadrado qué pasa
si yo elevó al cuadrado ambas cantidades
si yo elevo esto al cuadrado 0.3 por 0.3
estrés por 39 y estamos multiplicando
dos cantidades y cada una tiene un
dígito a la derecha del punto así que el
resultado debe tener dos dígitos a la
derecha del punto por lo que es punto
cero nueve y si elevamos al cuadrado
esto que nos va a dar pues el cuadrado
de la raíz cuadrada de punto 45 va a ser
igual a punto 45 y 0.9 es claramente más
pequeño que 0.45 o 0.3 al cuadrado es
claramente más pequeño que raíz cuadrada
de punto 45 al cuadrado así que sabemos
que 0.3 es menor que la raíz cuadrada de
0.45 con esto podemos decir que si el
22.9 por ciento es menor que esto y esto
es menor que esto otro entonces el 22.9
por ciento es menor que la raíz cuadrada
de 0.45 otra forma de hacerlo
es tomar nuestra calculadora y hacer las
operaciones sacamos nuestra calculadora
el 22.9 por ciento es lo mismo que el
0.2 29 así que queremos comparar esta
cantidad con la raíz cuadrada de 0.45
hay dos formas de hacerlo una vez como
lo vimos al principio elevar al cuadrado
esto y compararlo con el cuadrado de la
raíz cuadrada de punto 45 así que esto
lo elevamos al cuadrado y vemos que no
esto es 0.05 2 441 lo cual es bastante
más pequeño que 0.45 así que esto valida
lo que ya habíamos encontrado o podemos
hacerlo de otra forma podemos sacar la
raíz cuadrada de punto 45 y compararla
con el 22.9 por ciento así que tenemos
0.45 y le sacamos la raíz cuadrada nos
da que 0.67 y un poco más la raíz
cuadrada de este valor es
aproximadamente igual a 0.6 7
que es aproximadamente el 67 por ciento
lo que es mayor que el 22.9 por ciento
así que hemos visto varias formas de
resolver esto algo bueno es tratar de
aproximar esto y es bueno tratar de
estimar estas cosas mentalmente ya que
lo podemos resolver aún cuando no
tengamos acceso a una calculadora
podemos darnos una idea de qué bueno si
yo tengo el 22.9 por ciento de descuento
en el precio de algo y a lo mejor esto
lo puedo comparar con la oferta de otra
tienda que no se tiene un descuento muy
sofisticado de la raíz cuadrada de punto
45 de descuento en todos los productos
lo cual sería algo bastante interesante
de encontrarse aunque sea algo bastante
confuso para los clientes de cualquier
manera yo espero que esto les haya sido
útil